zhang tao has two one dollar bills
so two one dollar bills so let's just
write that as one plus one because each
one dollar bill represents one dollar so
one dollar plus one dollar that's the
two one dollar bills one five dollar
bill
one five dollar bill so that represents
five dollars
and three ten dollar bills
three ten dollar bills so that's plus
ten
plus
plus 10. how much money does he have in
all
well let's see one plus let's see if we
calculated 1 plus 1 is 2
2 plus 5 is 7. so these are going to be
and then 10 plus 10 plus 10 that's three
tens so that's going to be 30 dollars
now what's seven ones plus three tens or
what's seven plus thirty well that's
going to be thirty seven dollars
so zang tao has 37
in all let's do another one of these
thea has six one dollar bills and
actually let's draw it out
dia has six one dollar bills so that's
one
two
three
four
five
and six and these are one dollar bills
so they
so one dollar bills
this is my my rough drawing of one
dollar bills i have to draw a lot of one
dollar bills here so
she has six one dollar bills
she has three five dollar bills
let me do that in a different color
so three
five dollar bills
so one
so that's a five dollar bill
two
that's a five dollar bill
and three five dollar bills
that little circle and that's supposed
to be the picture of someone let me make
it clear that's that's these are
pictures of
of folks of famous historical figures
so these are pictures of famous
historical figures here and then finally
she has one ten dollar bill
one ten dollar bill
so one ten dollar bill so it's worth ten
dollars
a picture of famous historical figure
right over there so how much money does
she have in all
well the six one dollar bills that's
going to be six dollars
the three five dollar bills that's going
to be worth five ten fifteen dollars
so plus
fifteen dollars and then the one ten
dollar bill that's going to be worth ten
dollars
ten dollars
so what's six plus fifteen plus ten
well let's see six plus fifteen is going
to be twenty one
twenty one plus ten is going to be equal
to 31 dollars is equal to 31 dollars and
you could have also added it this way
you could have said 15
plus 10
plus 6
them together and we would have gotten
five plus zero plus six is eleven that's
one one and one ten and then you have
three tens here
so thirty one dollars